Hello and welcome, everybody. It is
September 19, 2023. We're here
at the active inference Institute in
guest stream 58.1, and today
the session will be around the
experiences of those who have worked
with Gerald Edelman. Edelman lived from
1929 to 2014,
and as hopefully this conversation
can explore and unpack a little bit,
worked in various areas related to the
brain, body, and mind. So without
further ado, I will have our guests
introduce themselves, give a little bit
of a background on how they came to be
working with Professor Edelman, and then
we have several prepared questions and
several other questions. So thank you
all for joining, and perhaps, Andrew,
if you'd like to begin. All right,
so I'll just start a little bit with my
background. I did my PhD at University
of Minnesota, and then I
did my postdoc at Hopkins with Apostles
Georgopoulos and Vernon Macassel.
And then I got a job in Phoenix working
in a small neuroscience institute
or neuroscience department at a
hospital. And I worked there for six
or seven years. And my interest was
working with non human primates with
monkeys and studying how they reached
for different objects and drew objects
and then looked at the activity in
primary motor cortex neurons. And we
carried out different kinds of analysis
based on the directionality of the
neurons in motor cortex built
populations and were able to actually
look at these neural signals and see how
they corresponded in a pretty exact way
to the way the animals are moved in
time and space. In other words,
trajectories. And after
working there six or seven years, I was
invited to come and look at this new
institute that Gerald Edelman was
establishing in San Diego in La Jolla
and met a bunch of super interesting
people like Guilio Tononi and Olof
Sporns. And really,
their deep intellect and curiosity and
creativity has convinced me to move to.
I ended up moving there. And so Edelman
was able to build this gorgeous research
facility on the Tory Pines
cliffs, basically, and it
was a magnificent architecture.
And he recruited a number of people
besides sparns and Tononi,
and so he divided the group into
theorists and experimentalists. And I
was an experimentalist, but we would
have lunch every day together as a group
and discuss different topics.
And I was really exposed to a whole new
way of thinking about neuroscience in
terms of sort of the cognitive aspects
of it, which I still have difficulty
with, to tell you personally, because I
don't even know how you define
cognition. And I'm not sure that anybody
really can, or as Vernon Machasto would
say, I don't know the answer to that,
nor does anybody else. Maybe Karl would
take issue with that. But anyway, the
coolest thing about it was being really
exposed to a lot of creative thinking
and deep intellectual endeavors, and
I've really never regretted the seven or
eight years I spent there. I think it
really helped change the way my career
went from being sort of a motor control
strict, sort of very
careful scientist to using my
imagination a lot more than I would have
otherwise. So I'll leave it at that.
Awesome. Cheng Ming okay,
yeah, I can speak about my
journey with Dr. Edelman. So I was
originally from Taiwan. I graduated with
a medical degree in Taiwan university in
78. But I was very interested in doing
basic science. So I applied a PhD
program and got into Rock Federal
University and that started to
search for a laboratory. And certainly
Dr. Ederman is very
powerful intellectual capacity building
in the building it was on 9th floor of
the Bronx laboratory. I was very
impressed. So I joined the laboratory.
So since 78 to 83
I was a PhD student and
I was working on the topic called neural
cell adhesion molecule. So at that time
Edelman already got his Nobel prize for
immunoglobulin. But he would be usually
elegant way would say I solved molecular
recognition. So he said I don't want to
stay in immunology to collect more
awards. He said I will work out cell
recognition. So in his mind how cell
recognition work is through a group
of adhesion molecular interaction. So
that's how he started to work on the
cell adhesion molecule and duty's house
actually work out the chicken cell
adhesion molecular. So when I joined the
laboratory, my PhD things was work out
the first mammalian cell adhesion
molecule. And in addition to NCAM,
though, I supposed to work out on these
adhesion molecule mediating the Neurolog
cell recognition as he said he would
say. I asked him also after all what
would be my PhD thesis and he would say
ming, when I start to write a poem, I
don't know how it's going to end.
That's the way he would put his language
there. So he just figured out retinal
tectoprojection I'm
hardworking student so I would work out
on that. And as you know, these days our
so called systems biology approach,
right, is these transcriptome single
cell RNA sequencing to identify a
non biased way to identify molecules
involved. At that time the so called
systems biology approach was making
monoclonal antibodies. So I would be
there taking out the brain and the
retina and the tectum and produce
I produce 18 batch of the monochromatic
antibody against these neuronal cell
membranes. So I certainly have
identified a lot of adhesion molecule
but none of them really
show a very distinct pattern these days.
I think the field using the
transcription factors was able to
identify some patterns but at that later
it's kind of all altogether. But I
remember that actually anyway, I didn't
really figure out retinol technical
projection but that's enough for me to
graduate. But at
that time I also still remember how I
actually had a great impact on my
professional career. So I was cutting
chicken spinal cord cross section to
mapping these cell adhesion molecules.
So I have some feather chicken feather
hanging outside there, and they stand
with this NCAM with the most beautiful,
exquisite pattern.
Later work on the feather as my major
research model, kind of as a rosetta
song to understand the language of
morphogenesis. But there I remember how
I started that. You have these feather,
they form these branches. So these
branches are actually originally formed
cells. Then they die to become space.
But before they die, they actually light
up with NCM. Light up with NCM with the
most exquisite pattern there. So you
kind of say, okay, you're going to carve
out this region. You light up with NCM,
you light up with sonic, and then other
signal coming to say you die. But before
they die, they light up that pattern.
So the feather pattern is very
exquisite. Radio symmetry, bilateral
symmetry, bilateral symmetry. So Adam
was very impressed by those findings.
I appreciate he actually encouraged that
when he sees something, he appreciates
he encouraged it. He didn't say, oh,
you're supposed to work on the brain or
whatever. He actually like it. And
subsequently he also developed this idea
of topobiology, which he would
acknowledge to say it's sort of based on
the very exquisite pattern we found in
the feather. But of course he developed
it further. But some other time he would
say, if this is not in feather, I am
adamant I'm going to get another Nobel
Prize. So I like it. Let him encourage
that direction. So later when I became
independent, I sort of say, okay,
brain is wonderful, but it's all like
being curved inside. I don't figure it
out, but I'm not that smart. But I might
be able to figure out feather pattern
formation. So I have a reasonable,
successful career. Figure out the able
debo of the feather, but as I said,
not just feather itself, but use feather
as a rosetta stone to figure out
morphogenesis. And that
sort of I think I appreciate that he's
encouraged on that. Also, as you know,
the stem cell biology comes along and
the feather in a bird baby chicken is
one way. Adult chicken, male, female,
all looks differently, but they are all
from the same group of the stem cell
that my lab have stemon straight. So it
is the so called stem cell niche would
be modulated by sex hormone, by age, by
season, by temperature, and let them
help you produce different feather forms
to adapt to the environment. I think
I enjoy my research career and it was
obviously have his impact. And I think
he's intellectually brilliant and always
encouraged going after fundamental
principles, saying that if you're going
to work on a question, ask most profound
questions and approach with the most
available technology, current technology
of the day. Don't waste your time on
small questions. And I think I have
taken those in so I can stay up to here
and we can discuss more later.
Thank you. Awesome. Karl hi.
So my name is Karl Friston, and like my
two colleagues, I found my stay with
Jerry Edelman both foundational and
very, very formative. I was quite early
in my research career when I joined the
neuroscience Institute. Having trained
as a psychiatrist, I got into brain
imaging. And at the inception of brain
imaging, people were for the first time
discovering principles of functional
brain organization, such as the
principle of functional segregation and
subsequently principles of integration,
how segregated specialized parts
of the brain communicate or are
coordinated or are integrated together.
And one of the key theoreticians and
neuroanatomists that authored
this particular interpretation and
deployment of neuroimaging was Semir
Zeki. And semir zeki. For those of you
who don't know, he's still very active,
one of the architects of neuroaesthetics
in his late retirement now, but he was
friendly with Jerry Edelman, and Semi
was famed for understanding
the computational anatomy of early
visual cortex and visual cortical
hierarchies. And I repeat, the
principles of functional specialization
and integration. So after a couple of
years at the inception
of human brain mapping, using positron
emission tomography and establishing,
for example, the color center in a
particular part of the visual cortex, I
was effectively sent to New York.
So my period of engagement was
a fellowship between about 1990 and 1992
93. So this slightly predates Andy,
and it covered the translocation of
the Neurosciences Institute from the
Rockefeller University to La Jolla
and under the auspices of the script.
So I spent half my fellowship at the
Rockefeller and then subsequently
watched the building of the magnificent
neuroscientist Institute on North Tory
Pines Road that Andy referred to with
the auditorium, if I remember, designed
by imported experts in audition and
music and sound engineering from Sweden.
It was really an amazing place. I do
remember a couple of lunches before I
returned to the UK to pursue my
career in imaging neuroscience under the
auspices of the welcome Trust, but only
a couple because we were sort of in
rented accommodation from the script on
the other side of the road. But it was
an awe inspiring bit of architecture,
both intellectually and practically in
terms of the early days of the
Neuroscience Institute. So I was
sent there basically because Sami
Zecki thought it would be good for me to
go and work with Jerry Adelman
retrospectively. I now appreciate that.
I was sent there to replace a gentleman
called Reed Montague, who had
been tasked with on the pure theory
side, as opposed to the celadesian
molecule and the wet lab side of
Edelman's research. On the pure theory
side, the point of my arrival,
and to a certain extent at the point of
Reed's brief exposure to
the neuroscientist institute, the theory
of neuronal group selection was becoming
consolidated. And in particular, what
drove the selection of neuronal groups,
neuro ensembles, cell assemblies,
however you want to describe them, and
given Edelman's polchamp
for incredibly incisive and
straightforward but very creative
biological thinking. He thought, well,
it's obviously some kind of natural
selection and therefore there must be
the homologue of adaptive fitness that
is underwriting the scaffolding and the
dynamic structuring of
connectivity or connections that were
definitive of in the spirit of
functional specialization, segregation,
but also the mediator of functional
integration of these neuronal
groups. So this became known generically
as value. So Reed was working on value
dependent learning the plasticity and
the principles that underwrite which
synaptic connections have the right kind
of adaptive fitness in their mileage.
In that context that enabled them to
persist and other connections went away
and became or contributed to
the sparse coupling of neural networks.
And then Reed, and we can talk about
the glorious stories about the departure
of Reed. Reed actually ended up in
a rather circuitous way with Terry
Sejnowski at the Salk subsequently,
then hooked up with people like Peter
Diane and Wolfram Schultz, who at
that time was in Zurich. And of course
the story that emerged from that was the
reward prediction error story that
actually, ironically, Reed did not. But
a number of Wolfram eventually got the
brain prize for some decade or so later.
But the inception of that story was
actually at the Rockefeller. And it was
basically an
attempt by, I think, Reed to formalize
the principles that must be
in play to make the theory of neural
group selection under what
was an important dynamic from Edelman's
point of view, which is this notion of
reentrant dynamics. So very, very early
on he had identified the fundamental
importance of recurrent connectivity and
reentry as very formative in the
emergence of these structured groups and
the associated functional
specialization. Just open brackets,
just to point out that you
could claim that certainly his early
conversations with people
at that time sort of preempted stuff in
computational neuroscience that we now
take as for granted, not really
realizing where it came from, but
certainly his work with Vernon Mancast.
I'm sure Andy will be able to speak to
this later on. On the importance of
reentry and dynamics and oscillations in
the formation of these groups and sort
of cortical. Columns and the like. That
was sort of, I think, the monographs
that they not the monographs, but the
papers and the articles they wrote at
that time I think were quite visionary.
Steven Grossberg was also hanging around
a few years earlier, and I think you
could probably claim that between the
two of them, they invented computational
neuroscience. Certainly know New York,
Boston, sort of East Coast kind of
style of computational neuroscience,
closely involved with something called
the Neuroscience Research Foundation,
so that they, as I understand it and
again, Andy may want to correct me here,
but this was like the forerunner of the
Society for Neuroscience. It was a group
of people. People, and perhaps Max Cowan
is the name that comes to mind, people
who actually invented words like
neuroscience, which wasn't a thing,
certainly when I was applying to my
undergraduate studies and trying to
create institutions, academic
institutions, that would endorse this
notion of neuroscience. And the
Neuroscience Research Foundation was
like the old guard. And then the Young
Turks came along and reacted against the
old Guard, the Neuroscience Research
Foundation, to form the Society for
Neuroscience. And then we all know the
story since that time. It's one of the
biggest societies in academia.
So just making the point that Aidelman
and his colleagues and vicarious
colleagues, a lot of people, oliver
Sacks being one, ernst Mer being another
of his favorite sort of characters to
talk to, all of whom would come and
visit, and we were privileged just to
listen in. And conversations in this
very formative time where some of the
sort of, I think, conceptual pillars of
the way that we understand neuroscience
in the 21st century were
first articulated, probably not using
quite the same words that we use
nowadays. So no one talks about reentry
anymore, so about recurrent neural
networks or sort of feed forward and
feedback and the like, but the same
underlying dynamics. And maths, I think,
is absolutely there. Anyway, I was
brought in to replace Reed Montague,
so that was my little contribution.
Whilst we were in the Rockefeller,
I made the mistake of thinking that the
right way to do this was to actually
write down equations and try and sort of
naturalize it in terms of mathematics.
Edelman was a great biological thinker.
He was not a very good mathematical
thinker, so there was a bit of a clash
there. So I remember one
meeting very early on when it was being
decided what I was going to be doing.
Perhaps it's useful just to say the
context in which those early meetings
took place. So Andy has already
mentioned Guilio Tononi and Olaf spawns.
They were two key people, edelman's
young men who already in sight,
you. And then I replaced Reed,
and they were working really purely on
theory. And that theory was tested in
the context of a forerunner
of supercomputing, a hypercube that was
driving, in my day, little robots. So,
again, Edelman was doing neurobotics in
the 1980s in exactly
the same way that people now in
developmental neurobotics are still
addressing exactly the same questions,
probably with the same kind of computer
infrastructure that obviously upgraded.
So we were sitting around and Edelman
was called out to take a phone call from
Germany, and there was a look of horror
on people's faces because I'd suggested
a relationship between value dependent
learning and the riskola Wagner rule
from behavioral psychology. And as soon
as you mention an equation or a formula,
that set Edelman off. And I didn't know
that, so I didn't know I pushed the
wrong button. So when Edelman came back
in, I was effectively rusticated. I was
prevented from doing any work for three
months and for every day,
afternoon and morning I had to sit in
the Rockefeller library and read purely
biological great texts, and I
ended up having to. The last one was The
Growth of Biological Thought by Ernst
Mayer. I had to read from page to page,
and when I did so, I had become
sufficiently sanitized to be allowed
back into the workplace to actually do
some work anyway. So that was our
contribution. And then when we moved to
the whole parade of 16
Wheeler traxxas, translocating all the
kit and all the paperwork to
La Jolla, and then relocating out there,
settling down, I brought that work to
closure. And interesting, that was at
the point when Giulio well, Olaf, I
remember him saying what he wants is
basically to understand and simulate
the brain in a way that draws
explanatory power from the architecture
of the connectivity. Basically, we say
he wants to establish connectomics as
a discipline, and of course, ten years
later, he's Mr. Connectomics. Julio at
that point was inventing integrated
information theory with a particular
focus on information, theoretical
formulations of complexity, and what
special, if you like, counterintuitive
behaviors, do you get from these
biologically configured connectors when
you put dynamics on structure and trying
to quantify that in a way that
ultimately transpired to be measures
like phi in IIT. So that
was a fun time as the mathematician,
closet mathematician, because I wasn't
allowed to say anything about the maths
at the time. I enjoyed that bit. And so
looking being in
at the, if you like, ground zero at
the inception of all these aspirations,
which eventually led to very fruitful
careers. And then I went back to
the UK. Just had fond memories and
non fond memories, but both of a
nostalgic sort since that time.
Awesome. Great tales. Changming or
Andrew, anything you want to add? Or I
can go to one of the questions.
Well, just to expound a little bit on
what Karl was saying, I don't know if
you can see this book. Okay, so this
was something that came out of the
neuroscience research program that was
sort of the old boys club that Francis
Schmidt started at MIT and
later was the basis for the
neurosciences Institute. And what this
was was sort of the who's who in
neuroscience. So, again, if you look at
this book, it says, edited by Francis O.
Schmidt. So he was the guy that started
that.
This persisted even throughout
the 2000s.
Once or twice a year at the
neurosciences Institute, they would
organize one of these meetings, and it
would be a who's who of neuroscience.
So all the Nobel laureates in
neuroscience, all the big names, would
come for a four or five day meeting and
talk about their research. And as a
member of the neurosciences Institute,
I got to sit in and meet these people.
And it was phenomenal, especially with
my background, because I was sort of not
on the mainstream of neuroscience at
that point. And that was really
fascinating. So you got to meet people
like Wolf Schultz and all the big names
that were there, francis Crick.
But what I want to go back to is this
original book by Edelman and Mac Castle
called The Mindful Brain. This is sort
of like one of the bibles of early
creative thinking about brain function,
and it presaged the idea of
distributed systems. This was sort of
the thing that Vernon Moncasso was very
much into. And so to this
day, the way most people think about
brain function is boxes,
where each part of the brain is confined
to a box, and then there are arrows
pointed to other boxes. And so we get
this idea that there's a circuitry. So
you often hear neuroscientists talk
about circuits, and that kind of comes
from the idea that you have these boxes
and you have arrows and you have plus
and minus signs with the arrows, and
then somehow the pluses and minuses add
up and tell you what's going to happen
at the next box.
And that is nice because
you can kind of simplify things and talk
about causality in very concrete terms.
And it's great if you're an engineer,
because you can write transfer functions
about defining how you get an output
from an input, but that's not
the way the brain works. And I think
Kyle can attest to the early days of MRI
studies where everybody was doing
pseudocolored representations
of these different areas to see which
area would light up a particular task,
as if each area had a specific job and
could be assigned to a specific task.
Neuroscience in general is still
suffering from that point of view, and
it's only become a little bit more clear
as computational science has matured in
the last five or ten years, especially
with the adaptation of artificial
neural networks to the mainstream, that
we can start to explore more biological
meaningful ways of brain function. And
Vernon Macassill recognized that as
sort of the I would say the founder
of systems neuroscience, modern systems
neuroscience, and Edelman talked about
that a little know, there's group theory
and some of the things that OLEF has
started. With graph
theory still sort of based on strict
anatomical you know,
if you read like Olaf's latest review,
where the field is starting to progress
away from that constraint of anatomical
connectivity, we're starting to get more
toward the idea of truly distributed
systems. And to me, that's super
exciting. But you can look back to this
book from the see that the
seed was planted way back then and see
how almost 50 years later, now,
it's finally starting to evolve into
something that's becoming more
mainstream. And if you sort of look at
the evolution of neuroscience, I think
if you project ahead to the next ten or
20 years, this is going to be really
the fundamental change in the way we
think about neural function. And I'm
super excited about that and you look
and sort of back in history to see how
that's evolved. And I don't know,
I think there's something very
attractive about thinking about things
that way. Yeah.
Okay, I'll add something, I think,
talking about Edema's,
the brilliance about seeing things
through. I don't know. In the
neurobiology field, you people still
sort of think the neuro Darwinism idea
is still there, right? So that was the
time when I was with him in Rockefeller
University he would talk things like
know Darwinism for evolution species.
And he saw that in immunoglobulin
chronos selection. So he applied to this
neurodarwinism idea. But I have to say,
subsequently, actually, my career is
mainly in university, Southern
California and working on this
morphogenesis tissue patent formation.
And in our field, sort of more bench
work aspect of Edelman. This direction,
not the neurobiology direction, but in
the field, there were people originally
more talking about the stem cells are
predetermined and then they go this
lineage. They go this lineage. But we
using the skin as a model. Actually, I
start to write these things kind of a
Darwinism within the skin. I mean,
basically it's that there is no preset
forever stem cells. If you wipe out
these stem cells, other cells are
waiting there to take over the space.
So there is even during development and
during regeneration to make the tissue
patterning process robust. There is a
small so called Darwinism competition
going on in there and that is sort of
also influencing our work in
morphogenesis these days. And I think
that's kind of the impact of him
on this aspect as well.
Wow. All right. I'll read a question.
This was from Dave Douglas. Dave wrote,
we know that Professor Edelman used deep
analogies in exploring new subjects as
in his leveraging his knowledge of
immunology and organismal development to
probe conceptualization and learning.
Did he ever work specifically on
metaphor and analogy as such? For
example, did he leverage his experience
of music and poetry to dig out
scientific facts while separating
fertile from sterile analogies?
An answer or just what that makes you
think of?
It makes me think of something which
Edelman used to call me, which I am an
intellectual thug. So I'm sure that
there's a great answer to that.
Excellent question. And it does speak to
Edelman's skills and interests. As a
violinist, I do remember that BBC
Horizon came to do a profile on
him and his ideas and it was prefaced
with, I think, shots of him playing
the violin to concert standard. But I
have absolutely no idea whether he used
that sort of part of his life to
take things beyond metaphor. So as an
intellectual thug, I'm going to hand
over to my two colleagues to see whether
they can give a more elegant answer.
Or anything in that area of the arts.
And you brought up poetry.
Anything in the arts and sciences?
Well, I'm no brain biologist,
but just to say that from my side of the
interaction, he really tried to merge
science and art. He would think a
real science would be beautiful. And
that's the way I think when I learn. As
I mentioned, when I say, oh, I was
expecting a more clear cut CC's idea,
but he would say Ming is like writing a
poetry. He said, When I start, I don't
know where it's going to end. It's like
some artists when you ask them how do
you create this painting? I try to ask
this question to some of my friends who
are artists and they say they
do not have a clear blueprint of how
that painting would looks like. They
have an idea, it's kind of floating in
the sky and they try to grab it down,
so they paint on the way and try to make
it into a painting. Or I have a friend
who are poets, I ask them this, they say
they grab the word to make them coming
down. And I kind of feel adamant sort of
treat the scientific idea like that.
This is my superficial interaction,
just some experience. I don't have
a direct reply to that. But in
general, I think there's the idea
of creativity that he brought to
the forefront. And then also with
that creativity, you have to have a
certain amount of courage to move
out of the sort of mainstream,
right? So if you have an idea and you
have to have a certain amount of courage
to put that forward.
If. That idea is creative and out of the
ordinary. And I think artists and sort
of really great scientists have that
in common.
Maybe to that nexus of creativity
and career development and courage for
you or just in the environment. How did
his mentoring help bring out
these threads in people?
For better and for worse? I think Karl
could attest to that. I have a hard time
viewing Edelman as a feel good
mentor. I think he
would throw ideas out there. He could be
pretty aggressive and I
would say frightening to young people.
So I wouldn't
cast Edelman's behavior as sort of the
typical mentor. But again,
I think the environment that he created
was someplace that was really special
and reflected that kind of courageous
creativity. And I really
appreciate that. Now.
Just to endorse that notion of
courageous creativity, I think it's a
really nice observation. I've often
reflected on whether let's
take for example, Julio and Olaf,
and I think you could probably apply it
to me and Andy and a number of other
people as well. But if we just take
Julio and Olaf, who've both become world
leaders, thought leaders in their own
particular field, having brought
something new to the table, and in some
instances in more than one area. So
Julia TENone, in terms of sleep research
and synaptic Homeostasis in terms of his
work in consciousness studies,
integrated information theory, olaf in.
Terms of structural function and mean.
Is it that Edelman had a good eye for
bright young men? Or is it that bright
young men learned how to do this? That
this was the way to be courageous and to
say it's an adversarial in that courage
to be creative and to pursue what you
have created in a slightly adversarial
or at least sort of defensive way,
I don't know. But what I do know is
there was certainly a culture that
was established that would allow those
kinds of skills to be developed
and is referred to them slightly
obliquely. It was a dark culture
and it has to be said, it was a very
homophilic culture. There were no women
allowed in this culture. So in
my time, the culture was really
one man and adoring young men
and you had to repeatedly
affirm that adoration. And part of that
was really useful and really enjoyable
and has already mentioned the lunches.
Exactly the same regime characterized my
stay. There was a rigorous routine where
all the young men would go off to the
New York cafe, would have onion rings
and burgers and Aileman would wax
lyrical. And perhaps this is not art
and creativity, but he was
artistic in his joke telling, so he'd
always have a new joke every lunchtime
in a New York diner. And that was a
routine and it was just pure theatre,
day after day after day. Incredible
energy, but it was theater. The young
men were the audience and we basically,
I think, were dancing to
his orchestration. He was the conductor
and he was the director.
It's possible that that culture did
actually instill in all of us, and
particularly Olaf and Julio, the notion
that to make it to make a difference and
to be true to one's convictions, you
really have to sort of fight for and
autonomously pursue what you want to do.
And it is interesting that the style in
which both Julia and Olaf have pursued
their scientific ideology and ideas and
creativity is very much slightly
lonesome. With the exception of Julia's
work in
the molecular biology of sleep, the
theoretical contributions are very sort
of associated with them personally,
to a certain extent, with me. And what
one could argue is the
mathematical version of value dependent
learning, which would be the free energy
principle. All of these things have the
same flavor as neural Darwinism, or as
some people used to call it,
neuralmanism.
So I often ask that question was this
the skill of Edelman in choosing people
who are going to make a difference or
did he basically provide a culture in
which it gave people the tools or the
motivation or the confidence that you
can make a difference because you saw
him make a difference? I don't know.
I think both of you actually said
something. I shared the experience.
Definitely he set up a right
environment. But just like when we do
stem cell, stem cell and its niche. You
need the interaction. You need a
conversation between epiphelia and the
methanchyma cells or in the brain. I
heard it's more like interaction between
neuronal cells and gulia cells. So a
successful interaction would lead,
whatever the process, to move forward,
but not every process would
be successful. So, as said, I also like
the way Karl mentioned about Edelman is
the conductor. He actually said that in
our meeting at the time. He said,
Edelman, I'm the conductor. You guys is
my symphony, prayers, and you
pray together. You can make a good
music. But it's also true not
every interaction works, because I was
with him for almost eight years or so.
Not every person work, let's put it that
way. That is a fact. So some work, some
don't, right? So I think people are
given that opportunity. And as Andrew
said, it's a good, outstanding
environment. So you pick up the
idea from Edelman, you develop yourself
and some of them, or you can call it
Edmund, then we success in
a certain way or not, but I think it's
an exciting environment. I would put it
that way. It's both. He inspires
you. He gives you a sort of
exciting environment to evolve, but not
everyone. He can choose everyone to
be successful. No, it's not like that.
But he did give you that opportunity to
be successful and to pick up something,
and he also give you that courage to do
it. As I mentioned, people would
normally think using the feather as a
model is kind of very high risk,
but he has that encouragement, and I do
that, and I feel I really using Federal
as a Rosetta Stone. I have learned
something for the Morphogenesis patent
formation field. Yeah. So I appreciate
him for that.
Andrew. Or I can ask another question.
I really don't have anything to add
right now. Thank you,
though. It's really amazing.
It's such a different world, and the
environment of learning and of carrying
out science is so different. So,
personally, I really appreciate just
even a window into settings that are
elsewhere and in a different time. So
thank you for all of this.
All right, I'll ask another question
from Dave.
Professor Edelman was reputed to be
skeptical about the risk of abusing
mathematical or computer models in
creating theories of neural functioning,
cognition, and consciousness. Some
reviewers went so far as to mock him in
print for using computers as research
tools. But he worked with Tanini
on the foundations of integrated
information theory, an extremely math
heavy theory that sometimes explained
using computing imagery. Did Edelman
change his attitude towards the role of
math or of computing paradigms in
thinking about the mind? Or did he
simply start trusting his colleagues to
think computationally without falling
into rabbit holes dug by von Neumann and
Turing?
Or how did you see the role of math and
computers in Edelman's thinking and
research develop over a period where
they were also undergoing such rapid
developments more broadly. So I'm pretty
sure that Edelman respected mathematics
and computational approaches to
neuroscience. There certainly
were a lot of theory fellows that were
computationally savvy. While I was at
the so,
for instance, Karl mentioned these
robots that were used to sort of explore
and learn, sort of the beginning, I
guess, of embodied cognition. Karl, you
would say, where they explore the
environment and learn, and then from
that learning, they build internal say.
And that was Olaf's ballywig, I would
say that was highly computational and
certainly a major thrust in edelman's
emphasis in what he wanted to do at the
institute. And there were a number of
other things, I think, the integrated
part that Julio did. I think that was
almost all Julio's work,
along with some of the other
computational you
know, I think Edelman wanted to be part
of that, but that really, I think,
was mostly,
I think, you know, as part of the
culture, edelman managed to get his name
on Julio's paper. We used to laugh about
that quite a bit, but again, I would say
that was 99% Julio's work.
Yeah, I can concur, because I was there
when the work was actually done.
There was a sort of period I
can't remember there was some hypothesis
that pertained to a core, a dynamical
core, as sort of
oppression are necessary for some kind
of consciousness. And I think Ehlmann
was comfortable with this sort of
intuitive notion of a dynamic core, but
when it became articulated in terms of
information theory,
I think even if he didn't say so out
loud, he would have responded as he
responded to me, with, oh, you've got
mathematosis. So this is another of
his ways of dealing with
people who had a tendency to over
mathematicalize and oversimplify, as a
physicist would, reducing a horse to a
point and then writing down differential
equations. He was very allergic to that.
He didn't like that and would call that
an instance of mathematosis. I think
that's very distinct, though, from what
Andy was just talking about, which is
the commitment to physically realized
embodied computation.
And I think it's a really well observed
point that this was embodied cognition
circa 1980, 1990. So he was quite
visionary in, I think, sort of testing
out ideas in physical in realized
systems. You couldn't just hand wave
with maths. You had to show it worked.
This idea worked in a real setting.
And at that time, they were the
Darwin series to the extent that
I, for example, had to spend six months
learning to paralyze C in order to
program the robot. So it wasn't he was
frightened of new technology or computer
science. I think he didn't like
trivializing things. All a physicist
with mathematics, but you would
certainly be fully committed to the
notion that computation is at
the heart of the kind of dynamics that
he wanted to understand. And underwrote
theory and indeed, I think that the
theory of neural group selection speaks
to that. He wanted to see it realized
in a robot. But I think Andy's
absolutely right. At the point when
Julia sort of just basically went
straight from the axioms to
consciousness and phi with equations. I
think that was the time that Julia had
to leave the family, basically, and
Julie did so. Sort of
extrapolated that a little bit think,
you know, when I read Edelman's books
and some of his papers, I don't
understand his, you know,
his phrases and his descriptions. A lot
of things don't make sense. If he had
written those out or someone had written
those out as equations that's the nice
thing about equations. Once you see the
equation, you don't have to worry about
the words so much. Things become pretty
clear. And I think, looking back,
if he had been able to do that, I think
his ideas, first of all, would have been
crystallized in his own mind better and
second of all, would have been able to
be others would have understood them
more clearly. And I think that's really
important for me.
Maybe with an engineering background or
something. If you have a model or
if you have an idea, if you can write
that out explicitly with an equation,
it really clarifies things, it
crystallizes things. And that was the
thing that I liked about Julio's work
because again, this word of know, it's
like nobody knows what that really
means. But at least Julio had a
form of equations, right, where he was
talking about information theory and the
know, you could have a cluster
where information was internal versus
the external information and say, that
okay, if you have to have consciousness,
here it is. And he could describe that
with a concrete equation. I mean,
that's a step forward. And again, I
always say as someone that records
neurons in the brain all the time, if I
wanted to find consciousness, how would
I know it if I found it, right? I mean,
if I had an equation, maybe I could do
it. But just the way it's defined right
now, who knows? I could have already
discovered it. I wouldn't know. So I
think that's an interesting point.
Anyway, I can't resist his following up
on that because especially evident for
me in the remembered present this notion
that his words don't actually make any
sense. I think that's pure poetry and
pure brilliance because what I tend to
find myself doing is reading the meaning
into his ambiguous sentences and finding
all sorts of meanings which wouldn't
have occurred to me otherwise. I think
that's part of his art. I suspect that
he would have been terrified if somebody
had actually come along and tried to
time down to a clear formal,
naturalized mathematical formalism
because he wouldn't have had that sort
of biotic expressiveness and
ambiguity that, of course, is at the
heart of his evolutionary thinking. But
I think it's great that you, Andy, are
able to say you don't understand what he
wrote, because I look at some of his
sentences. What on earth is he trying to
say here? And of course, but the
exercise of trying to make sense of
Edelman itself brings to the table some
really interesting sort of associations
and ideas. I'm wondering whether that
was part of the secret of his success,
is that he resisted the temptation to be
crystal clear and just left that
mystical, magical ambiguity hanging in
the air for people like you and me to
worry about and try to resolve. I
suppose he's given that privilege after
winning a Nobel Prize. I think some of
us mere mortals wouldn't be afforded
that luxury.
All right, I'll read a few more
questions. We can have a few more
things. So, small questions. In the book
Topobiology Changming, did you draw the
feathers, or is that your work?
The feather is my work, yeah. It's based
on my work. Awesome.
Well, how do we take
things forward in science and
in our work here in this
level of the fractal with this amazing
story and history with Edelman? But how
do we take our historical and our
mentoring context? Like, how do you
carry that forward? Is it something you
think about?
I personally do, and I congratulate
myself every day on not being like
Edelman when it comes to mentoring.
How so? I'm not going to
answer the how so question, but you
could read between the lines whether
that's the right thing to do or not. I
don't know. I don't think you could be
Edelman now. In 21st century.
We'd be too close to all the culture
wars, I think, to even entertain that
style anymore. And I suspect that's
quite a good thing. Although pressure
makes diamonds, and as Andy says, it was
an exciting both my colleagues have said
it's an exciting, informative time. It
was a pressure time. It was a dark time
for me in terms of the
dynamics, the systemic, the personal
interactions. But because it was
pressured, it made diamonds. And so we
may be throwing away the opportunity to
make academic diamonds and be truly
creative in terms of making things that
endure like diamonds by not having that
style of mentorship. But I don't think
it will be even legal nowadays, to be
quite honest, to run a lab like Edelman
ran.
So, again, I think that
over the years, neuroscience, I don't
know about the rest of science, but it's
almost become sort of industrialized.
So there's a method as
a young person,
when you finally get your own job, you
have to set out. And if you're at a
university environment, there's certain
boxes you have to check off. You have to
get a grant, you have to get a certain
number of papers, you have to get
something in science or Nature in order
to get promoted. There's these steps and
I think young people are so focused
on moving through those steps at
the point in their career where they're
going to be the most creative and their
minds are the most flexible and they can
be the most productive. And I
see that as a shame, actually,
that they're not given this opportunity
to be a little freer in
the way they accomplish things. And then
when they do accomplish some modicum of
success, they rely on their past
behavior. So instead of saying, okay, I
had to go through that in order to get
tenure, now that I have tenure, I'm free
and I can do something that I really
want to do. That really doesn't happen
because people get stuck in a rut. And I
see that as really holding back progress
in neuroscience. And that was kind of
the cool thing about the Neuroscience
Institute. For better or worse, we
weren't allowed to go out and get our
own grants. We had to rely on internal
funds. But as a result, the only person
we had to convince was Edelman in order
to get funded. And to a certain extent,
that allowed us to do things that were
really creative. In hindsight,
I think that was a mistake, because
financially, that was doom for the
Institute. There could have been a
hybrid approach that would have been
more productive. But then again, as Karl
was saying, the investigators would have
had to have more freedom to do that,
and that was not exactly in the culture,
although I think I was an outlier
because I maintained a separate lab.
So I was somewhat inoculated from that,
and that made it a lot more pleasant for
me. But again,
I see that in current neuroscience,
it would be nice if people were willing
to take more chances and be
a little more creative instead of hoeing
to the status quo.
That would be, I think, what we need
in order to move forward.
Yeah,
no, I think that in terms of the
mentorship that Karl was talking about,
I mean, certainly I have seen people do
very well, but I also have the
opportunity, sort of when I moved to
University Southern California, to have
some interaction with Dr. Simo Benter.
And some of you probably know him. I
mean, you would see actually he is also
very successful, but when
he came out, he would always have his
students surrounding him very kindly.
I think that Edelman is
brilliant, but it's kind of the sun is
too bright. Sometimes people
have to be distilled into the, as you
say, academic diamond. That's
interesting. So we also have seen some
people didn't get along with him well,
but still, I think there are many
impact. He certainly have encouraged
many people go different directions.
And in terms of the academic
the academic future right. I think you
two are more talking about the
neurobiology side, but on the
morphogenesis side, I would also say he
always emphasized the patterns thinking
that pattern is kind of the way nature
either biology, non biology, they leave
some clue for us to figure out. And when
I was there, I remember every time he
talked about the visual columns tolson
we saw they have worked out, he got very
excited. And in fact, I have one of my
peer at that time was working on the
visual columns of the cat. But I think
that paper that work never really go out
to be published. But anyway, on the more
practical things, I work on the tissue
patterns and I feel that you
mentioned about the top of biology. And
again, I think he coined the term, and I
think the term I think it means a lot
because eventually my career was trying
to figure out these signaling molecules.
Because at that time, people only talk
about signaling molecule. Very
important. But the idea of topobiology
is that you even position these simply
by positioning these signaling centers
in a different topology. You can
actually have a lot of consequence from
there and the signaling center can also
have a different lifetime, the strength
and the duration and the
range they can influence. So by
modulating he like these terms to
modulating these signaling center, you
can create a lot of regional differences
and up to now, as I say from my own take
bird, you look at it right feather here,
downing feather here, the beautiful
crown feather here, tail feather. But
these are all from the same genome. So
it actually is through the positioning
of these different signaling center in
a different way, and you basically have
the same ingredient, but you can play
with them by topologically,
temporal, and especially arrange them
and to create a quite complex pattern.
I feel that in the tissue patterning
Morphogenesis side, I feel that
his vision is great, and I think we
still try to work out more about how
these patterns are positioned. But I
think that's sort of the direction in a
more visualized purple biology aspect we
can appreciate.
Awesome. Well, perhaps if each of you
would like to give any closing thoughts.
Yes, to echo those
last sentiments, I think everything
that Adelman said or tried to
say, depending whether you could
understand him, I think he's absolutely
right. And we are slowly discovering the
truths we've just heard about top
ofology and the importance of patterns.
And of course, if you speak to somebody
like Mike Levin, he'd be talking about
exactly the same thing. He'd use words
like basal cognition and pattern
formation. But I think that we're
talking about the same principles of
biological self organization and
edelman. I didn't know about
turbobiology, but I do know there are
other fundamental ideas that he just
incidental to him. I am absolutely sure.
I think notions of degeneracy in the
neurosciences and psychology, the notion
of many to one structure, function
mappings, for example. These are
fundamental ideas which now are taken
almost for granted in my
world, but you sort of forget how much
he actually contributed or at least
laid the seeds for, and sometimes very
explicitly so, it should be
acknowledged. Although he was, as Mark
Rakel put it, in his typically
gentlemanly fashion, edelman was a very
complicated man. He was also very
brilliant and is responsible, I think,
for a lot of the direction of travel and
the intellectual growth, certainly of my
intellectual growth, but I would say
also many aspects of our academic
communities. Thank you,
Karl. Perhaps Andrew oh,
unmute and then please continue.
So I would know if
there's anyone listening out there,
there's something to be said about maybe
looking back in the ancient
literature that goes back quite a bit
and maybe seeing how some of these
things came about and trying to put it
together and see that there's this
iteration that constantly takes place.
People rediscover the same thing that's
been discovered multiple times and
try to see how there is a
status quo in the way science works.
And then there's these outliers where
there's sort of creative bubbles that
come to fore. And I think it's
interesting to think of Edelman and the
things he did and the people that were
associated with him in terms of sort of
these disruptive, they call it
disruptions and how
those disruptions may have consequence
many years later. It's kind of
interesting if you take the long view.
So I think it's maybe worthwhile
thinking about this once in a while and
for young people out there to be
encouraged to think
out of the normal way of doing things
once in a while, try to foster your
creativity and have the courage to go
after some of those ideas. I think
that's a take home message for me
anyway.
Yeah, I would say I always like
all sort of influenced by his idea,
saying that we should study the
important question that have a general
meaning. So I think that kind of ideas
he said that, look at the big pictures.
I remember when I was there, he talked
like that, the big pictures. So that is
where when he thinking about the
Darwinism, he would say it's not only
for the species evolution, for the
immunoglobulin chronos selection, he
would push it to the brain theory.
And for me, I work on the morphogenesis.
I actually would come to realize that is
also what happened at the tissue level.
These cells are competing with each
other to form that patterns and then
pattern is selected. When there is a
functional advantage, it will be
stabilized. I think the idea of saying
if we're going to do science, we ask big
questions, ask for the generalization,
I appreciate that. And certainly he is
like how you want to call it, right? A
huge elephant. So we all touch him
through different side and have a
different take on that. In terms of
the young scientist, I also remember he
likes the Chinese proverb I cited to
him. That is to say, if you want to get
Tiger's son, you must get into Tiger's
cave. So with three did.
Thank you all. That's a great note.
Really appreciate this conversation.
And again, thanks. Until next time.
Okay. Thank you. Bye. Nice meeting you
all. Bye bye. Thank you.